well it is costing a little more in some
cases a lot more to keep up and keep
warm this time of year a rise in energy
costs is a lot of people upset i've
never seen a response to a story in our
newsroom like we've had for this story
with the cost of natural gas going up a
lot of you have noticed that your
southwest gas bill looks a lot different
and a lot bigger sasha loftus spoke to
some who are feeling the effects of this
recent hike she joins us now live with
more sasha
denise and brian this winter has been a
lot colder than years past and suddenly
people are having to pay a lot more to
heat their homes with natural gas now
those i spoke with today say this price
hike is not making things easy for them
it's really hard right now it's
something we've all been seeing
everything is more expensive the bills
the power the gas it's everything now
southwest gas is raising its prices and
people in las vegas say it's been a
nightmare i just got this bill yesterday
and it says 100 and was 130 dollars many
tell us their bills have doubled or even
tripled over the last month
so we asked the company why this is
happening they responded with a
statement that says in part the increase
in customer bills is likely due to
natural gas prices between 2020 and 2021
as well as increased gas usage during
the winter months the sudden increase is
crazy because gas always was the
cheapest in november the energy
information administration said natural
gas prices are set to be a third higher
than this time last year citing overall
supply issues to not use the heater and
still see an increase it's it's
ridiculous regardless those we spoke
with say the steep hike is uncalled for
and ask southwest to consider what it
means for families trying their best to
just get by we don't need more increases
we're barely making it as is
southwest guest did send an alert to his
cars around november saying that they
would see around a 30 percent hike in
natural gas bills though some we talked
to tonight say their increases far
surpass that now as for the company's
statement we have a look at that full
statement on our website right now
8newsnow.com
reporting live tonight sasha loftis live
local now